une facile à chaque fois donc comme tu
as menti on va te faire une interview
mensonge d'accord j'arrive pas vous
voyez philippe excusez-moi mendy moitié
ou c'est mieux ben alors donc
l'interview mensonge il faut répondre
sans dire la vérité
le vote ouais est ce que vous pensez
qu'une ville d'alaska une bonne ambiance
à canal oui beaucoup
est ce que vous pensez philippe gildas
que votre émission actuelle est un
succès oui est-ce que jérôme bonaldi
vous étonne tous les jours oui est-ce qu
alain de greef a toujours deux
merveilleuses idées joker est-ce que
c'est pas un petit peu dommage qu'on
n'ait pas vu cette émission avec
laurence belkacem équipe à dos
oui est ce que c'est vrai est ce que est
ce que vous vous est divisée est-ce que
vous c'est vrai que l'émission que de
fogiel et ruquier samedi matin avec
savanna nom de plus est ce que c'est
vrai que vous ne ratez pas une
à la question est mal formulé non et
sinon vous êtes content que lagaf et est
élu personnalité de l'année où cette
barre oui est-ce que c'est tout moi je
trouve ça très grand projet je m'excuse
j'ai pas menti ah bon ouais t'as pas
menti tenons bon j'espère que vous m est
ce que c'est vrai que prendre des micros
rapport est-ce que vous est ce que c'est
vrai qu'avec maryse vous fréquenter les
boîtes échangistes
oui c'est là où il a échangé maryse est
ce que c'est vrai que j'avais un sexe
énorme oui
je vais vous fumez 15 pétards par jour
oui car c'est une rencontre
ouais nan 15 personnes l'empruntent avec
gentil en personne oui alors qu'elle
fume pas parce qu'elle dit que c'est pas
bien de fumer parce que ça empêche de
bien travailler ensuite web à la
jamaïque c'est comme ça qu'elle saura
disent tous les cinq ans montrent
maintenant tous les trois qui veut dire
travailler quand tu travailles c'est
bien d'un métis il faut combler ce
loisir aussi le loisir de travail est
bon pour allumer les lumières serge s'il
vous plaît voilà alain bonsoir